good morning everyone how are you good
after kovid dealt the uk the biggest hit
of any major economy in 2020 the
chancellor wants to put the recovery
center stage despite omicron the economy
was actually remarkably brazilian we
were the fastest growing economy in the
g7 last year and we're forecast to
continue being the fastest growing
economy this year as well so that shows
that our plans for the economy are
working
while the recovery is relative a
national insurance rise and rampant
inflation are real and if salaries
aren't keeping up the chancellor says
that's not his business we have millions
of different companies in this country
all with different sets of employees and
needs for employment some are growing
some are shrinking some are short of
staff some are not it's right that all
those individual conversations take
place between all those people it's not
the government's role to come in and
mandate things for the entire country
for this hydraulic parts specialist it's
not just wages that are rising the
energy bill has doubled and the price of
everything they buy has gone up
this year we gave the biggest pay rise
we've ever had but i'm worried about
with inflation that our people
still will not have enough
particularly with ni and such like
coming in
for hospitality 2021 had a sting in the
tail as omicron killed the christmas
trade and the full impact of rising
prices for commodities like coffee is
yet to arrive
we've seen the price of uh commercial
coffee has literally doubled in the last
12 months
these things are going to trickle
through onto the high street they're
going to affect the consumer and they're
also going to affect the customer
workers like kirsty are already feeling
the pinch
when i do grocery shopping i have
noticed it's gone up so you're having to
like kind of cut things that you don't
necessarily need and you're trying to
like balance out like what i need and
what i don't need
to try and keep the price the same the
gdp figures tell us that with every wave
of covid the economy and we as consumers
have got better at living with it and
the economy as a whole is now the same
size as it was before the pandemic the
worst is probably over but with
inflation and taxes rising this year it
might not feel like it
for workers the hard craft of growing
the economy may just have begun paul
kell says sky news in reading